hi everyone and welcome to new people
today we receive Christina Naja is the
head of the europa websites neither
Greek nor a girl track we will talk
about a personal story the EU and how
she ended up managing one of the biggest
website in the world we will also test
our internet pop culture and see if she
can match your sense of humor so join us
and meet the women behind your plea
[Music]
I am here with Christina no yet
Hungarian from Budapest and mother of
two she arrived in Brussels as one of
the first TV reporter from an Eastern
European country you might have seen her
on my attila video if you were watching
in the late 90s but now she's hiding
behind the hyperlinks of the Europe our
web pages welcome Christina Christina
are you know if anything I'm a digital
conservative digital conservative what
do you mean well that I like digital but
only if it is well done I really like
robustly well things that work for a
long time that have been well thought
through and I'm not necessarily falling
for gadgets or very attractive things
you arrive in Brussels is one of the of
the first correspondent from an Eastern
European country but how was it at that
time to report about the EU even before
Hungary was a member state even at that
time we have never seen ourselves so far
removed it from the European Union and
this was by the way one of the very
interesting discoveries when I arrived
that many people considered Europe only
as the western part of it whereas since
my birth I've always considered myself
as a European and from our perspective
we were always Europeans I learned that
when you arrived there was quite many
crises in Europe and so you arrived
directly during the crisis can you tell
us about about this the track of events
that was very important at this moment
in time was the crisis in the Balkans
and the war in Kosovo so we were
basically sleeping and pictures of you
back in Kosovo did what was happening in
here so you were there so for number of
months we were covering the crisis many
journalists here from NATO headquarters
and then we were told about the day when
k4 troops were entering Kosovo and we
were encouraged to go there and and
cover the situation on the ground and
well on the photo what we see is already
a few days after we arrived to Kosovo to
Pristina when I was discussing with you
cheek a soldier in the street and and
learned about all the things that happen
it was historic at that moment
you feel something really important was
absolutely and I mean this was not in
particular the Kosovo situation was was
really really not just historically but
also personally very shocking for me I
have seen there things that I could have
never imagined that is possible to see
that that ethnic cleansing can indeed
happen at the door of the European Union
at that time and actually it also showed
me the importance of the European Union
and and the European Union as a Peace
Project let's get to know you more
I've got some speed dating questions for
you so I'm going to put you in front of
two choices
two simple choices and you're going to
tell me which one you prefer so it's
simple we got one minute and let's see
how far we can get ready ready
tea or coffee coffee in the morning tea
in the afternoon cats or dogs
8 a.m. or 8 p.m. 8 a.m. goulash or
cabinet Budapest or Brussels Budapest
Hungarian or English Hungarian consejo
English English say spare suit or
sweatshirt sweatshirt discussion or
debate discussion sometimes debate
communication or information
communication journalist off
spokesperson journalist interesting
decision or compromise compromise but
many people will say I'm more into for
this DNA screen or on the ground on the
ground I strike Monday motivation or
Friday feeling Friday feeling angry
birds or candy crush
none family or friends boss restaurant
or picnic picnic and being in your
twenties or being in your forties roof
forties
[Music]
so in 2004 you decided to quit
journalism to join the European
Commission as a spokesperson how come
well I had a little Intermezzo before
the spokesperson ship I worked very
shortly with the first Hungarian
commissioner in his cabinet and I was
extremely interested by the challenge of
looking behind the curtain so when you
have been covering EU Affairs for a
while it is really really intriguing to
see how the machinery works behind how
these policies are being elaborated what
are all these people doing so I was very
excited about that it was the most
difficult in being a spokesperson did
you lose your freedom of expression
because you were journalists before so
you were quite quite free to say
whatever you want and then you become
spokesperson so well I don't think that
things are so black-and-white if you are
a journalist you also don't see what say
whatever you want but whatever facts you
find on the table and you have to be
very objective it's not about your own
personal opinions but what is difficult
in being a spokesperson difficult part
was when you come from journalism and
from a community of the press room where
I really felt at home that was difficult
because obviously when it came to the
private conversations with friends I
could not be as outspoken as I used to
before I had to pay much more attention
to the things I shared with them the way
I spoke about events and people behind
that you were starting to to be
different with your friends I was not
different with my friends but I have to
admit that I avoided some situations
there were certain parties I didn't go
to or never know it happened
occasionally and I must say what was
difficult as well when some of these
very personal relationships were
following me in relative private spheres
like in a fitness centre a journalist
came up to ask me a question about my
job and that was really uncomfortable
because I would have loved to reply as a
friend but frankly I was not working
there so I was doing my my fitness so
it's not as well to ask question when
you're doing your fitness it happens
we found some old footage of you as you
wear spokesperson do you want to see
them wrinkled question anyway so oh my
god
[Laughter]
do you remember a tough moment in this
experience
how did enlargement go I guess there was
some also difficult isn't that yes of
course there were many difficulties and
delicate situations as a tough moment I
mean the really tough moment in the
everyday life is this the one we see on
the footage because standing on that
podium is extremely tough you don't you
never know what is the question you will
be asked has there been any crazy moment
in this time as a spokesperson there
have been many crazy moments one of the
crazy moments was when I lost my
Commissioner Olli Rehn at Vienna Airport
for some misunderstanding the gates were
very strangely organized he went to
another gate then I went and I went into
the plane and I couldn't find him
anywhere
and we had to call him and all the
stewardesses were running and they
wanted to close the plane and I was
almost in a hysterical outburst that no
I can't leave without my permission so I
have another short archive to show you
look at this the date is important he
was back on the 25th of February 1995 so
do you know what it was about this day
well the the day I wouldn't have
remembered that day sounds very familiar
to the birth of Europa it's it's this
yes the the big web domain that we are
managing and for which my team and I are
responsible at the moment at least for
the Coordination and governments part of
it so how did it look back then well it
looks like you see it with the many
little stairs stars and it looked as it
had to look at that time what was
possible to do with the technology at
that moment does it look right now
Europa is a whole domain including a
large number of websites it is
encompassing all the websites of all the
EU institutions and just as regards the
Commission the Commission itself owns
more than 800 websites this is already
and what we calculate in our own
Commission domain is more than four
hundred 140 million unique visitors a
year who are visiting our websites more
than 220 million times and how do you
see the website in 10 years in 20 years
we still exist I don't think that the
discussion is about a website's as such
we are in a very dynamically moving
digital world there are different
digital solutions and with social media
the website or tools or applications
this is not what really matters I think
what really matters is the journey we do
among those channels is how we discover
the information so I am coming from the
communication angle for me what matters
is how we use all this to communicate
something or to give access to a service
or to an information it's not about
technologies it's not about websites
they are helping us to realize a
different purpose we should not be
driven by the tools that are our hands
the tools should allow us to achieve our
objectives
I have a last game for you about the
internet culture we have here some
really nice mice from different ages so
I don't know which one you prefer
well the 1980s or the last one your
opinion Mouse I'm gonna ask you five
questions and your price will be better
each time you answer right a good
question safe because are you ready
could you give me three nicknames of the
at sign in different new languages para
buzz that makes one how many I have to
do three non Gary jung-gu cuts cuckoo
cuts and in German the next question
today there are as many web sites on the
world wide web as trees in the Amazon
rainforest cows in the world or stars in
the Milky Way view if I give you the
numbers of those the cow was right
answers it's 1.5 billion websites in the
world and also Cal's in the in the world
according to estimations are there more
cats or dogs memes online yes I would
say that's the right answer
actually some according some to some
studies there are more the cats ruled
the internet but the shelf dog's name is
growing faster very interesting that I
would like to know who do you remember
Tom why does heaps picture now belongs
to the internet culture Tom no so it's
actually Thomas under son and he was the
father of MySpace and actually his
picture was the first one to be
suggested as your friend on MySpace
and now it's become part of the internet
culture ok Mouse last question which of
the following emojis will not be rolled
out soon so we've got the ginger head
we've got the cold face we got the roll
of paper or we got a duck face duck face
that's the right answer that's the duck
face yeah but this was just a guess you
got it right so actually you go with a
within this nice Mouse but you wanted
that's the game story that will be for
our next guest so that's for you thank
you I hope you like it thank you very
much thank you for the answers thank you
for the game thank you everyone for
watching you can now comment share
online you can redo the quiz and I'm
very much looking forward to seeing you
again with our next guest
[Music]